hey everyone
well as you guys know um
i've been spending the last
months of my life
trying to piece together the
most profound things that i've learned
throughout my life pretty much
and the probably one of the most
interesting things that i'm learning
about this process
of trying to synthesize everything that
i've learned
is that
it's both the most challenging thing
in the world for me
and it's also the most rewarding thing
in the world
they come together at the same time
and the meta pattern is the most
precious ethereal thing it's like
the idea that there is
an ultimate nature to this reality and
that
your ability to
[Music]
uncover that unveil it
within is
paramount plus unleashing
a gift into the world so it's twofold in
the sense of
you both unveil
the ultimate nature of reality within
and you bring a unique gift into the
world
that seems to be such a central part of
all of the metaphysical
traditions across the planet and
it's just it's so much it's so
interesting because
there's a you can very clearly see there
is a
pareto power law
of profound
thinkers and profound
successes that have driven
humans moving forward and in order to
find yourself on that tail
end of the bell curve where you as
an outlier have produced a vast majority
of the enlightenment or
value for the world it requires
a ridiculous amount of work like you
can't
just netflix
and chill you gotta
do the really hard work so right now i'm
trying to at least
mention out along the way do a little
video along the way about this
process
and it's pretty intense there's a bunch
of docs that i have that are basically
distillations of the most it's like a
process
of distilling everything
and then trying to take that and put it
into art
and that's this it's basically a
cyclical process of that because you
distill
put it into art and then what you
realize is that
there's actually more distillation that
you can do
and then you're constantly learning new
things along the way
so you have to synthesize into the
distillation
for example most recently i've been
learning a ridiculous amount
about both the perennial wisdoms of
spirituality and non-duality
as well as quantum mechanics
and around quantum field theories
and around all of the craziness of
hyperbolic geometries and the infinite
universe
so trying to put that together into
add that to the distillation and the art
has been it's very it's very interesting
at some point
the input stream has to be in a sense
not only comp i think i don't know it
might actually need to be
completely off which is so crazy
like i've been telling a lot of people
that i'm completely offline which i
pretty much
am my phone is completely off basically
all day
almost every day but
regardless i had to hear about unity
2020 right
so there i had to connect to the
internet
to to learn about unity 2020 and try and
spread that
around the world as far as i could at
least with my reach
so it's really crazy
how you it's about like
you at some point like michelangelo has
to do the sistine chapel and only do
that for three years
and that's what you may have to do with
what you're doing as well
in order to make that divine impact that
you want to make with your unique
contribution by the way in terms of a
gift
after you do the process of revelation
within about the nature of reality you
simultaneously
become an architect like an enlightened
architect of
the fabric of existence and
you do things like try and make it more
conducive for people to achieve
their self-realization and gifts so
basically an enlightened architect is
one that
makes it more easily conducive and
less molasses in the way for other
people to
become self-realized and become
enlightened architects themselves
this entire process has been
a realization of the need to surrender
as well because there's always this
biological clock right that seems to be
ticking
within around wanting to produce
something
and
make tremendous value and impact on the
world and also simultaneously
being cool with the big cosmic play
that's happening
and being surrendered to that process as
well
it's a balance between asha the power to
make something happen and
which is effortless action and
we have a short video that we'll be
publishing on that
in a little bit um
i don't want to give away too much about
the about the synthesis
there's just so many fascinating
concepts i want to tell you at least a
couple
places for you to investigate
one thing that everybody should know
about is the word recursion
i think it's a very important and simple
word
recursion just means that the procedure
calls on itself
it's that simple and the really easy way
to think about it is like the seed of a
tree
so as in the process of a seed
actually has as one of the lines
of the process of a seed becoming a tree
is for the tree to produce seeds
which then become more trees it's the
same thing with humans
one of your lines of code is literally
to make another human
so it's that simple that's what's real
that's that's what recursion is
and another way to think about it is
oroboros right so the snake
eating its own tail and so
thanks nicholas appreciate it thanks for
tuning in and commenting
yeah so that's like the auroboris is the
other way of
thinking about that as well so literally
that
this entire reality
may in fact just be recursive and
that one of our lines of code is to
do the full auroboros is to
continue the process and
there's there's a lot that's coming
together in that big synthesis
simulation theory
the visual arts indistinguishable
virtual realities
um all of those things are just coming
together
in a big soup
of
a mirror that's what it is a big mirror
for us to realize the nature of reality
so that's an important word become
familiar with the words recursion become
familiar with the word fractal
go look at the mandelbrot set
become familiar with the word oroboros
these are just very simple
words that that give you
very big updates to
the way that you experience reality
another important word is holography
uh the recording of a light field
holography right
what does it mean if we think about our
life
as a conscious screen
or an aware screen that just constantly
happens
thanks alex thanks for watching i'm glad
you found it and that uh you're relating
um for all those that are new um our
channel focuses on metaphysics
science spirituality the synthesis of
those
so if that resonates with you subscribe
like the video share it with your
friends let's get this channel more
um more popping um
so
what you do is you you think about your
awareness and your consciousness
as a as a screen if you do that for even
a moment and you think about okay if i'm
a screen
let's start there and then there's a
movie that's happening
so i'm on i'm i'm an eternal screen
and there's a movie that's playing and
once you become quote enlightened all
you do
is just experience peace and happiness
while you watch the movie
that's it this isn't some
process of needing to go for 10 years to
india to learn this
yeah that's right yeah good comment that
you are this this this
explorer of this
movie and that you get to
play you get to be in this cosmic play
and the more that you
fall into peace and happiness and
love as the
complete surrendered witness to the
beauty of it
um the more you just have basically
im peaceful immobility nothing from the
outside world can
affect your inner peace
and happiness nothing
and there's a big
aspect of what is
being cooked in the mainstream culture
which is that
you are finite
and
also that you
are your body and that you
are
subscribed as a cog in the economic
machinery
and that the the culmination
of the last
especially couple decades of economic
machinery
just churning out people to cookie cut
into little
fits in the in the machine and people
believing that they themselves are just
consumers of of the material world
and that there is no kingdom of god
within that is veiled that needs to be
unveiled that needs to be completely
realized and unleashed
is extremely destructive
to human happiness
peace flourishing love
and it's a very first principled it's
all a first principle
really what is your mo what's your most
first principle thing
it's your awareness it's your
consciousness
there's nothing that's more first
principle
than your awareness and consciousness
so basically if you constantly
hone in on that interior first
principle of consciousness and you go
back
go back go back even more even more
even more what is that first principle
of consciousness and awareness
and how is it that
that is a shared consciousness
now that's exactly where
the paradigm of
modern day materialism is experiencing
a big struggle is with the investigation
of consciousness and they're trying so
hard with
anesthesia they're trying so hard with
fmris and eegs and these biometric
correlates to
consciousness your your
uh your echocardiograms your ekgs
um and so that idea of your microbiome
they're trying to find
all these different biometric ways to
prove consciousness
and the fascinating thing about it is
that it
may in fact be one
shared consciousness
and it's been talked about for 4
000 plus years this is not something new
that's what else is funny
we think like francis bacon in the
scientific method 500 years ago was the
beginning of
rationality and science but it wasn't
that's what's funny you got to drop that
as well you have to look back 4 000
years
to the vedic rishis of the upanishads
and you have to look back to the sufi
mystics
and when you do look back that far
what you find is that these
these these people were themselves
figuring out
what consciousness is experientially
they have this process
where they would say uh neti neti not
this not that eti
it is this it is that and that
process of figuring out what are the
best
rituals what are the best practices and
methodologies
for me to unveil and for me to feel the
kingdom of god within to feel what is
the infinite what
is the eternal these things have been
talked about for
4 000 years so it's not just like a a
small
recent window into consciousness either
super important for that to also
be fully understood and realized so
anyway
these are all the things that i'm
piecing together into this big synthesis
and that it is it has to be disseminated
via
art nobody nobody wants to
read a 500 page book anymore
nobody like peak book happened
in the 20th century and it's done the
21st century
is visual arts period it's moving into
the augmented reality space
it's all gonna be as visual as possible
and so the the the project the big
synthesis has
a ton of graphics and a little bit of
words
and that's just such a again a um
a critical critical part of it um
i mentioned this a little bit ago also
in the last video we talked about unity
2020 and what that
means for trying to solve the monkey
politics that are going on around the
planet and to be a leading figure in the
in the space of having nuanced
um dialectical focus as a central pillar
moving forward geopolitically
i think that's crucial again that's
articlesofunity.org
you can go watch the last brief video we
did about that
bill mcraven and andrew yang are very
good combo and duo
and brett weinstein thank you for
putting that forward
yeah i mean that's that's pretty much it
i just wanted to do a quick bit on the
importance of the like these reflections
on the synthesis as well
just so there's also a documented log
of what has been cooking and what people
can hopefully get
inspired by a little bit like go and
learn about these concepts
um they're they're paramount to
understanding and
also they're in a sense
they're the most first principled
there's nothing more important than
consciousness
and there's nothing more important than
metaphysics
nothing there's nothing more important
than that your consciousness
and awareness becoming fully
aware agnostic being of that
first and metaphysics
the nature of that what is the nature of
that consciousness
becoming that gnostic being and then
bringing forth
with your peace happiness bliss
creativity
bringing forth a gift into the world
a unique contribution of value into the
world
and helping other people do the same
thing so
that's it i love you guys very much
thank you for everything all your
support
and i'm pumped to share this with you
and bring a tremendous amount of value
with this synthesis so
um thanks everyone and definitely
um keep on the on the
constant love for investigation
of the consciousness the awareness the
awakening
within so love you very much thanks
everyone
big love share the video like it
subscribe etc you guys know what to do
peace thank you everyone